do you know what be the bigger person
means no you tell me so in life
especially as you keep doing your thing
there's going to be scenarios where
someone might hurt your feelings or
might be doing something you're not
happy about you know and the question
becomes do you do something nasty back
to them when they do something nasty to
you or do you have compassion and
empathy for them and you can be the
bigger person and be kind back to them
when they're not being kind do you
understand yeah because you know this
when someone's not being nice for most
people the natural reaction is to not be
nice back to them but if we can teach
the world that when someone's not nice
to you it usually means that they're
hurting
and that you that should be actually
double nice to them when they're being
mean to you well then I think the world
can be beautiful yeah you're right you
like that yeah